if you ever watch fox news and who could
blame you if you don't you might be
familiar with the face or name of
retired lieutenant colonel ralph peters
a longtime Fox News contributor on the
network
he has quit in shame self-described
shame saying he's ashamed of the
network's coverage and he emailed his
colleagues and that email has been
obtained by BuzzFeed and if his name
rings a bell and you don't watch Fox
News it might be because this is the
same guy who was suspended by Fox News
in 2015 for calling President Obama a
quote total [ __ ] we covered it at the
time during an appearance on the Fox
Business Network
I've excerpted just the relevant parts
of Ralph Peters email to his colleagues
explaining why he's going to be quitting
Fox News where he said quote I feel
compelled to explain why I have to leave
I swore to support and defend the
Constitution and that oath did not
expire when I took off my uniform today
I feel that Fox News is assaulting our
constitutional order and the rule of law
while fostering corrosive and
unjustified paranoia among viewers over
my decade with Fox I long was proud of
the Association now I am ashamed
Fox has degenerated from providing a
legitimate and much-needed outlet for
conservative voices to a mere propaganda
machine for a destructive and ethically
ruinous administration when primetime
hosts who have never served our country
in any capacity dismiss facts and
empirical reality to launch profoundly
dishonest attacks on the FBI
the Justice Department's the court the
courts the intelligence community in
which I served and not least a model
public servant and genuine war hero such
as Robert Muller all the while scare
mongering with lurid warnings of deep
state matcha nation's machinations I
cannot be part of the same organization
Fox News is now wittingly harming our
system of government for profit going on
to say as a Russia analyst for many
years it also has appalled me that host
who made their reputations as super
patriots and who justifiably savaged
President Obama for his duplicitous
faulty with Putin
now advance Putin's agenda by making
light of Russian penetration of our
elections and the Trump campaign and by
the way as an intelligence professional
I can tell you that the steel dossier
rings true that's how the Russians do
things the result is that we have an
American president who is terrified of
his counterpart in Moscow Fox News has
crossed the line for the guy who called
Obama a total [ __ ] right this is a real
hardcore ideologically committed right
winger and he is calling out Fox's
propaganda and calling out Trump as
being Putin's puppet and all of a sudden
he goes in the eyes of the Fox News
audience from conservative hero to
unpatriotic stooge as far as they're
concerned and I want to be super clear
here
Ralph Peters is no hero he is not even
an admirable person he has a long long
track record of the most horrifying and
disgusting views and statements he is
truly a raging clown but even he sees
what it is that's going on at Fox and he
talks about his decade with Fox News
during that decade Fox News was going
after Obama for his choice of mustard
right and Peters apparently felt okay
staying then so I'm not making this guy
appear to be a good guy in any way pat
but what I am Telling You is that
someone as heinous in their views as
this guy even sees what's going on
judging by that statement he wants a
virtue bestowed on him for making this
decision and he was a treated like a
hero but yet he was complicit for that
10-year period yeah but on the other
hand I think Fox News has gotten worse I
agree Trump administration began no it's
been and you know what I don't think
it's that Fox News has necessarily
gotten worse it's just that at this
point it's even harder to pretend like
we don't see what's going on like when
Bush was president and they were all
talking constantly about just how great
he is and how great everything is it was
at least a more coherent narrative in
terms of how the sort of ideologically
committed right winger would buy into it
but now it's getting even hard for the
ideologically committed right-wingers to
just pretend that the Fox narrative is
the accurate one and listen he made the
right decision
be it ten years too late right and now
FoxNews is going after the intelligence
community and he said that he served the
intelligence community yeah so he's
saying oh now it's like you're attacking
me it feels personal now yeah let's not
pretend that this is anything but a guy
who has been totally complacent and
complicit in the garbage from Fox News
who just sort of feels like he's been
pushed over the edge maybe partially
because he feels personally attacked by
the narrative from Fox News about the
Intel community right decision glad to
see him go not a hero should have done
it a decade ago today's program is
brought to you in part by celcius which
is a new global peer-to-peer financial
platform that connects holders of
cryptocurrency assets with borrowers and
it will also allow crypto holders to
earn interest on their assets in the
form of coins or get US dollar loans
against their crypto assets it's sort of
like how having a savings account in a
bank works right just by having crypto
in your celcius wallet you'll earn
interest on that crypto but unlike a
bank
this is blockchain based your coins
become part of a decentralized and
crowd-sourced lending pool and you'll be
able to earn interest daily without the
profits going to traditional financial
institutions and you can instantly
borrow against your own coins and
Celsius intends to lend only with
single-digit interest rates regardless
of credit score and Celsius sort of
wants to stick it to Wall Street and
revolutionize the financial industry and
they are running an ICO an initial coin
offering which you can learn more about
at Celsius dot Network slash crowd sale
in the US it's open only to accredited
investors and you can sign up at Celsius
dot Network slash crowd sale this is not
financial advice please do your own
research and due diligence before making
any financial decision